what is it to be a man's man today I
mean I grew up wanting to be a man's man
that's what you wanted to be but today
it's toxic masculinity right you're
hearing it everywhere people are being
canceled for being a man's man but the
reality of it is 1944 a man's man was
storming the beaches of Normandy and uh
they knew most of them were going to
lose their lives but they're like nope
I'm doing this because this is what men
are supposed to do today people are
storming the beaches of their couch to
play Call of Duty 40 50 years ago
without social media we had to go learn
how to pick up girls and flirt and have
lines and be rejected today you just
gotta swipe right years ago you have to
learn how to hunt to get your food today
you just call ubereats Lots changed our
men become in pansies are they becoming
soft are we becoming passive like oh my
gosh betas is that what's happening I
got a bunch of data I want to talk to
you about that has to do with what we
bench press 30 years ago versus today's
squat you know our grip strength bunch
of different things that are influenced
and meant to become softer and for some
of you that are watching this that
complete greatly disagree with my
message I would love to have you watch
this message and post your commentary
below at the end of the video
stick around television I got a quiz for
you to take to know exactly what you're
driven by but it's important for us to
look at some of the data to know if this
is just gibberish or how our men really
viewed and what kind of a life men live
today before we get into it I just want
to give you some stats on is there any
relevance in men really struggling today
like they can't find themselves are they
really becoming software or not Scott
Galloway wrote an article the title was
the most dangerous person in the world
is a young man who's broke and alone let
me read some of the statistics that he
has in this article men are more likely
to use almost all types of illicit drugs
at a high rate than women thus their
higher prevalence of emergency room
visits and inpatient substance abuse
treatment 93 of prison inmates are male
as are 98 of all death row inmates men
are dramatically more likely to be
homeless and for longer periods of time
men now account for 41 of college
enrollments down from 60 percent in 1970
men are twice as likely to overdose
three and a half times more likely to
commit suicide and more than nine times
more likely to be incarcerated a recent
study revealed that 9 out of 10 Mass
violent attackers were male and more
than two-thirds of them were under the
age of 35 once again the most dangerous
person in the world is a broke and alone
young male Scott Galloway recommends
three things start making money we are
living in a capitalist society yet super
strong you want to be fit you want to
lift heavy weights and run long
distances in your mind and in the gym
and last but not least get out there
commit to meeting people and quite
frankly try having sex so interesting
three points he makes right start making
money today get super strong and finally
get out and commit to meeting people but
are we not stronger today than we were
before let's take a look at some data to
see if men are stronger today than maybe
20 or 30 years ago there's three things
I want to look at I want to look at our
bench press 2 before squat as well as
your grip strength they say your grip
strength is a strong predicator of
mortality in later life it's always
stronger today or before here's what the
numbers tell us so they surveyed 1800
lifters ages 20 to 39 to see what the
average bench press was 30 years ago
versus today and here's what they came
up with what the average man could bench
press 30 years ago versus today 30 years
ago was 240 pounds versus today 187
pounds squawk was 277 versus today 225.
so when you look at this data how do you
process a grip strength bench squat like
why are we looking at this data maybe
just maybe they're trying to get women
to become stronger and meant to become
weaker maybe maybe I'm wrong I will tell
you at our vault conference we have with
a couple thousand people there business
owners entrepreneurs I challenge
everybody to go to a certain
questionnaire the first night and the
next they come and share their
breakthrough with everybody while I'm
going through everyone a lady sitting
right here like seven rows right there
she gets up and she says Patrick I have
to tell you my breakthrough last night I
said what is it she said
for the last 20 years all I've been
trying to do is compete against men to
prove that I can make as much money as
they make I'm strong I don't need them
I'm independent I run a very successful
Salon I do very well for myself
everybody that works with me makes great
money I'm very very you know successful
right now to my friends to my peers I
said okay and where are you going with
this what's wrong with that
said the Breakthrough I have yesterday
is men are not the enemy I want a
husband
I want to get married I want to have a
family
how interesting is that right
the person she wanted to beat the entire
time now she wants to marry
how many endless videos can we see with
women in their 60s who bought into the
feminist movement to make men and women
equal are sitting there saying I regret
making that decision because I'm single
never been married don't have any kids
and I'm alone
and I wish I would have married man I
wish I would have had kids because I
wouldn't have been alone today next
point is a lack of male role models in a
boy's life or a man's life so if you
look at some data here in 2019 some 15
million children in the United States
were living with a single mother that's
about five times more than those living
with a single father as divorce rates
rise and family courts continue to favor
mothers the amount of boys living
without a dad will continue to grow so
why is this so important well there are
certain things I can tell my boys that
my wife can't tell them period I can go
tell my boys we're going outside and
we're playing they have to listen to it
I can go tell my boys you have to read
20 Pages a day they may tell Mom Mom I'm
good I don't need to read today I don't
need to do this I don't need to do that
there's just certain things my Dad could
have told me that my mom couldn't tell
me there's a very very big value that
men have in a boy's life but the more
divorces we get and the more fatherless
homes that we have men don't know what
it is to be a man's man matter of fact
let's look at a completely different
angle most kids who go to school most
teachers are women most teachers are not
men so just recently had my kids watch
Captain the document about Derek Jeter
and there's a scene in this documentary
where Derek Jeter is drafted by the
Yankees his dream becomes a reality
always wanted to be a short stop for
them because that was a short stop he
goes but he's not doing well he's making
errors he's making mistakes he's doing
all this stuff and he's having anxiety
attacks he's depressed almost and he
makes a phone call to his house mom's
talking to Derek and Mom says son why
don't you just come home the father says
when I heard my wife saying this to
Jeter he says I told her don't tell him
that he can't know that's an option so
now let's replay this say the father's
not in a picture
say to Mom's able to convince their
cheetah to come home because no mother
wants to see their son suffer and she's
witnessing her son Derek suffer but the
father says that's what builds character
let him go through it if that doesn't
happen you don't have a five-time World
Series champion few hundred million
dollars one of the greatest Yankees of
all time 3 400 hits if that simple call
by the father wasn't made you may you
and I may not know who Derek Jeter is so
what's the point here so maybe
meant they need stronger role models to
challenge them and to show them it is
okay to go through challenges it is okay
to have to fight through this is a part
of becoming a man's man and it's a
natural next point is the walking on
actual society that we're living in
today and what do I mean by walking on
eggshells people are afraid of offending
today okay so when you're afraid of
offending you don't want to share your
opinion and the way people learn who you
really are is by sharing your opinion
and feelings about different issues now
in our family I talk about four things
with my boys we lead we respect we
improve we love respect let's talk about
that if you constantly spend your life
disrespecting people you're eventually
going to be alone and not successful in
business because it doesn't work out if
you want to disrespect everybody people
are not going to stick around in a work
environment if you're disrespecting them
people are not going to be with you
friendship-wise if you constantly
disrespecting them and judging them and
quite frankly you're you're going to be
by yourself now offending is a different
story today okay they're trying very
very hard to cause men to be careful
with their thoughts and what they say
and God forbid you say something that's
going to offend somebody you're walking
on eggshells I don't know many leaders
that I call leaders who walk on
eggshells that are not comfortable
sharing their thoughts on different
issues they share their thoughts but
they get better at their soft skills to
know how to deliver their messages
better that's something you're going to
get better at for the rest of your life
but walking on actual Society where
you're sitting there by yourself not
really sharing your thoughts it's as if
you don't exist you're non-existent and
that's just not What men's men do the
next thing I want to talk to you about
is competition Society wants to convince
you that competition is not healthy for
you by the way the same people that are
selling you that are those who lost who
don't know how to handle it the reality
of it is socialist boys have limited
options capitalist men have unlimited
options in every aspect of their life
where they live where they travel to
where they eat who they date anything
you want there have an unlimited supply
of options and unfortunately those who
don't compete don't like the fact that
you have more options you know when I
was 14 years old I was playing this
Basketball Association for troubled
teenagers I'm in a league with
marasabatrucha with black diamonds with
you know the surenios 18 with the blood
[ __ ] all these guys and one day we're in
this tournament and only five of our
players showed up and we played against
a team that had a full lineup and we
lost by 104 points they gave us this
trophy that my dad has till today a last
place Trophy and he puts it right there
and he says you know why we have this
trophy to remind you how bad you lost
it's almost like experience the pain son
and I'm like dude throw that thing away
he says no you lost by 104 points look
at the psyche of a father your mother
would say why would you do that to him
that hurts his feeling like that's like
that's exactly what he needs the pain of
a loss makes a man come back and improve
makes him stay up at a late at night
practice and while everybody else is
sleeping makes this guy say one day I'm
going to prove to the world that I'm a
winner so going back to you there is
nothing wrong with competing there is
nothing wrong with losing as long as you
keep showing up and competing eventually
you're going to get your shot but you're
better off being a capitalist than being
a socialist because being a socialist is
just not attractive final thoughts here
look as you're going through the process
from being a boy to a man or from a man
to a man's man many times you're by
yourself say you don't have a father
figure say you don't have a strong male
role model you don't know who to talk to
you're trying to please everybody your
mom's telling you but that's not the way
to behave and you don't have another man
to bounce off the idea to think if it's
a good idea or not you're like okay I'm
gonna please my mom I'm going to please
my teacher who's a woman I'm going to
please my girl who is a female I'm going
to please my you know girlfriend's mom
you're trying to please everybody and
you're becoming less and less and less
of a man and you're in the car by
yourself saying man I'm losing my
identity I don't even know who I am then
you lean towards making bad decisions
look take the time out away from
everybody and sit down and say what do I
stand for what do you your values and
principles what do you stand for as a
man what do you want to do with your
life what kind of a leader you want to
be in your life you
who do you want to be not what
everybody's trying to force you to
become who do you want to be
but that and when you do that be
prepared for some people to not like it
that includes a lot of women in your
life
makes sense and then all of a sudden
you're going to be like oh my God I'm
finding more men like myself out there
fantastic they're out there they're
everywhere
you can find them just like yourself you
are not the only one that's thinking
what you're thinking right now
but you want to be a man's man the world
gives you more opportunities when you do
so we are living in a very very
competitive environment so if you got
value from this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel and I got
two things I want to share with you one
I made another video titled 20 rules for
young men if you've never watched it you
must watch this one and we have a quiz
for you to find out what you're driven
by you can click here or go to
peabodyquiz.com to find out what
motivates you and what drives you take
care everybody bye
foreign